my name is Dan Blanchard i'm here from
educational testing service or ETS and
today I'm here to talk to you about a
tool we developed for trying to simplify
machine learning but before we get into
the tool itself we're going to have a
quick history refresher so as some of
you may recall in 1912 there was a boat
called the Titanic and because of an
unfortunate event with an iceberg many
of its passengers ended up in the water
the lucky ones ended up in lifeboats the
not so lucky ones ended up just in the
chilly depths and because of this
obviously the ones who were in lifeboats
survived the ones who were not in
lifeboats perished but it's a thing
about this is it wasn't just luck it
wasn't like oh yeah I happen to be
standing next to a lifeboat you know
that kind of thing there are certain
properties about people that we can use
to predict based on this data set
whether or not people survived or not so
for one example we might say that
someone who is in a first-class
passenger who is female had one sibling
whether or not that's relevant we're not
sure and was 35 years old survived but
you know these other two people who were
you know third and second class
different genders different numbers of
siblings and different ages didn't
survive so the question is can we try
and predict survival from the data and
so this is the data set we're using here
is from the Kaggle titanic machine
learning from disaster data set and so
we've got 891 training examples and 418
test examples in case people are keeping
track so what we're going to use to try
and the tool we develop that we're going
to use a purchase problem is we call it
scikit-learn laboratory or sk ll
typically we just pronounce it as skull
for short because it's just easier than
saying sk ll over and over again and the
idea is it's worth a learning happens
that's what one of my colleagues coined
so first we're look at well first we
need to actually you know get the data
in a format we're going to use so in
this case the test set you download from
kagal doesn't have the labels because
the test set so for development we're
just going to split the training set up
into a training data and Deb set so
eighty percent in twenty percent split
and on our github page and our examples
folder we have a script that you can use
to do that for you called make Titanic
example data and you'll see something
pronounce something like this that says
you know loads it up and then it writes
out a bunch of different files so in
this case we've got we split the the
features that are available in the data
set up in so we try to like semantically
group them so we've got like
socioeconomic status information about
their family their vitals miscellaneous
is just you know whatever was left over
and then we have directories for
training development and then we have
one directory that's got both of them
combined in case we might want to use
all of that later so the next step if
we're going to try and you know do this
classification task is pick some
classifiers to try so in this case we're
going to use a decision tree learner a
naive bayes classifier random forests
and a support vector machine so we sort
of get you know a bunch of different
ways to try and approach this problem so
at this point if you were using
scikit-learn you'd normally have to you
know code up write some code to load up
the data set and a format that you can
use and then you know get get going but
in this case we're going to inset create
a configuration file which is how you
basically do everything with skull so
the config files are the simple like
config parser you know python config
parser I and I kind of format so in the
in the first section you can see we just
have general where we have the name of
the experiment the task is an evaluation
task which means that we're going to
train on one set and test on another set
the input section is where you just sort
of just talk about your you know your
feature files at your input so that the
train directory is a directory with
feature files for the training the
learner the test directory is obviously
a directory with feature files for
evaluating performance the feature sets
list we've got here it's a list of lists
because you could in one config file
actually try and do different variations
so you might have a list that just had
family miscellaneous one that had just
associated no economic and vitals can
sort of do a bunch of different
experiments all in one go by listing out
different feature sets so that's why
it's a list of lists so as I said before
we group the features up semantically so
families got number of siblings spouses
parents and children miscellaneous just
had departure port because I didn't feel
like that fit anywhere else socio
economics is the fare in the passenger
class and vitals is just the sex and age
next we have the list of all the
different scikit-learn classifiers we're
going to use and hear that the names are
just the names of the classes in
scikit-learn so if you're familiar with
any of the learners in there it's pretty
easy to just list those all out
something that if anyone saw my talk at
PI data last year so far everything is
pretty similar to what I talked about
last year but we actually recently
released skull one point 0 and as in
recently I mean yesterday so in that
release we added a bunch of new features
including these a ID column and label
well ID column this new label column was
there before but so if you're dealing
with a CSV files we used to require you
to like change the names of the columns
and the CSV file to be like ID is the
name of your column that has you know
the instance IDs and stuff like that now
you can actually just say ID column
equals passenger ID and you're all set
so that won't get treated as a feature
which would be kind of annoying then we
have the output section which says where
we want to store the results so the
results we store sort of three different
types of files we have first we have
sort of human readable results files
that list a bunch of statistics about
everything that happened confusion
matrix things like that then we have
JSON files that you can use for
automatically processing the results if
you want to write a script that does
something with them and then we have a
summary that will summarize for a given
configuration file you know like what
the performance was for all of the
different learners
all the different feature sets and
that's just in a TSV file so that you
can like you know load that up in your
analysis tool of choice and maybe you
know plot the performance and things
like that you can also serialize the
models by specifying a models directory
that will store all the trained bottles
so after we have this config file
created all we need to do is run it
through this tool we have called run
experiment and you'll see something like
this where it'll just print out about
the loading messages over and over and
over again if you're running this on on
your machine and you might think well
why are you wasting time loading the
data files many many times well that
that's because one of the things with
the run experiment is it was designed
sort of from the ground up with the
ability to schedule a bunch of jobs on a
derma compatible cluster so if you if
you've got like Sun grid engine or
something like that set up where you
work this will use a library we we we
also created called grid map to actually
schedule a bunch of jobs on the cluster
for you so because of that we just try
and save money and money memory on the
on the server that's actually submitting
all the requests oh we don't load we
don't usually load the files you know
and then send out the jobs with
everything already loaded the jobs
actually individually load the data
files so that you can just sort of have
pointers that you're passing around well
names of violins you're passing around
anyway so that's why that might seem
strange at first and okay that's all i
wanted to say about that so obviously
the next step is we want to see how we
did so this is one of those human
readable results files i was talking
about the you know the pretty colors are
because it's a presentation and i went
in and change the colors so sorry it
will just people i can wait if you look
at it normally but you can see you know
we have all sorts of there's actually
more information provided in the file
but i just wanted to fit on a slide so i
compressed it somewhat but we have all
the basics you want to know for
repeatability reproducibility later you
might want to know like what version of
skul we're using when you ran this
experiment what version of scikit-learn
did you have installed
how long it took everything like that
and then we've got this you know nice
confusion matrix at the bottom with
precision recall and F measure for each
class in this case the 0 is means that
they perished and the one means they
survived so you know with this basic
config file we created we're getting
about eighty-one percent accuracy on on
our little dev set that we created so
getting the results out of the summary
file that I was talking about before we
can see that for this task the random
forest classifier seems to do the best
which you know i think is a common theme
sometimes and you know decision tree
wasn't far behind neither was SVC but
multinomial naive bayes is you know did
about as well as we might expect them to
do so the next thing we can do is so it
is try and tune the learner so in the in
the previous case we were just using the
default hyper parameters for all the
classifiers which you know might be okay
but we can probably do better so or i
guess i answered my own question can we
do better than the default hyper
parameters so to do tuning you just need
to add a small section to your config
file the tuning section that says if you
want to do grid search or not and then
what the objective function is that you
want to train on we support a wide array
of objective functions basically all the
ones that are in scikit-learn plus a
couple more that we found useful in our
own work like quadratic weighted kappa
and things like that and then this shows
you what the tuned evaluation results
were so using tuning somewhat
unsurprisingly helps a little bit so the
random forest classifier gets even
better it didn't help for two of the
learners but you know it helps random
force an SVC you get a little bit better
but I should mention that tuning is much
better suited to larger data sets and in
this case we're using a very tiny data
set for this example
so now that we sort of have a rough idea
how things are going to work let's try
and use all of the available data to
generate predictions on the test set
because you know in the end if you're
doing a Kaggle task you want to actually
have something you submit to kagal and
have them tell you how well you did so
in this case we just need to change the
task in the general section to predict
instead of evaluate like it was before
we've just modified the training
directory to be trained plus dev which
is the directory where we had both
stored in and in the output section we
say we want to store predictions in a
folder we're calling output I should say
that you know all these directories I'd
say most of the time you're doing this
would probably be absolute paths but
it's just for simplicity oh it's just
using relative paths here so if we
submit all those two Kaggle
unfortunately there's no automated
process for doing that and they limit
you to like think it's 10 submissions
per day so to actually get these results
on this next table I delight you know
submit everything manually drag it all
over then wait till the next day and do
it some more so this table was hard
earned so we can see sort of across the
board there's a drop in in accuracy
versus was on the dev set which I don't
think is that surprising because we were
tuning on a very small data set and the
test set here is much larger than this
set was the dev set was before but still
in the end attuned random horse
classifier comes out the best and so we
you know we've done all these different
experiments but we actually didn't have
to write any code which is kind of the
reason we developed this tool in the
first place because we have a bunch of
people in my group who don't necessarily
do a lot of coding but they you know
hear about different classifiers that
are useful for things and they say I
have to stay it and I'm just going to
throw it at this classifier and see what
happens and so that's kind of what skull
Scylla dates you can just say I'm gonna
try every classifier in scikit-learn and
see what happens so so just discuss some
of the cooler things we have that aren't
just config files so we can read and
write our
CSV JSON landslip SVM Megan n DJ is just
another extension for JSON lines it's
just new line delimited JSON and tsv
data so one of the nice things about
that is that if you want to run the
experiments with skull and then say
check out how Weka can perform on the
same data set you can have an art file
that can be read by Weka and by skull or
if you want to use lube SVM directly or
mega M directly any any of the files you
know will work with both we have so to
facilitate the tuning we have parameter
grids that we've sort of pre specified
for all the learners that we support
we've put a bit of work in trying to
make those pretty reasonable so they're
not there's not like a million different
points in the grid so that it takes you
know 10 years to do your search but it's
also not you know just like try one
setting or another so if you're curious
about what those look like we have those
listed in our documentation and you can
actually override them if there's some
better parameter grid that you have in
mind for your particular problem a cool
thing that we added yesterday well tip
the release that came out yesterday is
you can you can now have custom learners
so not just the base learners that come
with scikit-learn you can also use
anything that's influenced a base
estimator interface from scikit-learn
you can use you just have to specify a
path to be python module in your config
file I mentioned that we use grid map to
do a lot of parallelization of
experiments because typically we're
running huge numbers of experiments on
our cluster the huge number of
experiments typically come from our
support for ablation experiments so an
ablation experiment for those who don't
know is in an experiment where you try
basically all in the H most extreme view
it's all combinations of features but
usually it's just you try all the
features but one or all the features but
to you can sort of set the number and
then you keep repeating that until
you've tried you know all of the
combinations like that so if you've got
a bunch of features doing that is going
to create a whole ton of jobs on your
cluster if you've got cluster or just
completely swamp here machine
no machine we also added the ability to
collapse and rename classes from the
config file so the example I usually
give is if for some reason you were
working on a task of say classifying
pictures into you know pictures of
animals and do dogs and cats maybe
initially when you approach this problem
you've labeled the data with like
individual breeds of dogs and then later
you decided that that was ridiculous
because it made the problem harder so
you just decided to collapse the classes
into you know just dog you can do that
pretty easily by specifying a little
mapping in the config file that says
like you know beagle and dachshund go to
dog and you don't even need to modify
your your actual files which is nice for
if you change your mind back later we
have support for all the psychic learn
feature scaling stuff so you know
standard even eight standard deviation
and mean scaling to try and get your
features between negative 1 and 1 which
can be important for certain learners
it's just a matter of specifying scaling
equals true in the config file if you're
doing regression we can actually we have
rescaled versions of all the regressors
so that you can rescale the predictions
to be closer to your observed data which
can come in handy in some particular
cases we're also all about command-line
tools so we've got tools for joining
filtering and converting feature files
so if you've got a bunch of feature
files i want to put together split up or
you've got a csv file but you'd like to
try using that same file with live SVM
in addition to using it with skull you
can convert the lib spm there are
actually people out there who only use
our tool for converting data file
formats which you know makes me a little
sad but you know at least are you seeing
it for something and then last but not
least we actually have a Python API too
but since you know we advertise this as
you don't have to write any code that's
you know not our emphasis but the Python
API is pretty simple there's like a
learner object that has basically
methods that correspond to all the
different tasks that were in the config
file so if there's like evaluate predict
cross validate that kind of thing
so here's our lovely list of currently
supported learners so we've got some
that are just classifier some that are
just regressors and then some that there
are both so this is all of the
classifiers and regressors that are in
the choosing the right estimator flow
chart on the psychic learned
documentation so how we don't do any
unsupervised learning yet it's not to
say we won't in the future it's just
that's what we needed at first was just
supervise so that's what we covered I
would like to take a moment to
acknowledge all the contributors to skul
other than myself and so these are all
the other contributors basically all
from ETS except for Neil's who was an
intern at ETS but he's from the
University of Pittsburgh and that's
ordered by a number of commits in case
anyone is keeping track and so that this
sort of has we know working at the data
set where you can get skull itself if
you want to see the ridiculously long
skull one point 0 release notes because
I'm just it took me forever to write
them so you know someone please read
them then we've also got you know read
the docs documentation which is much
better now than it used to be we've got
a tutorial on there which is basically a
text form of this talk and also got yeah
we just sort of reorganized the
documentation in case anyone saw what it
looked like before it wasn't that great
and as I said before all the configs and
data splitting scripts are in the
examples directory on github and that's
mostly what I had to say so thank
sugar so that's the best we got on that
particular task I mean we've used it for
other cago competitions and actually you
know done pretty well but because there
was a keg well uses as part of models
that we've used for Furcal there was the
automated scoring there were two
automated scoring competitions ASAP one
in a SF two that were for automatically
scoring different types of constructor
responses for tests and since that's
like what we work on we we did pretty
well in both of those competitions but
we don't really work on modeling Titanic
survivor data so so yeah this was just
like a little example I put together
Andy so the question was how do we
distinguish continuous and discrete
variables I guess under the you mean for
prediction like for labels right so
we're using the dict vectorize we're
under the hood so anything that's you
know categorical and string value it
gets you know the one hot encoded turned
into binary features right for integers
we're not really doing anything special
for integers we're just you know
treating them like numbers I don't know
if you have a reason to think that
that's the wrong thing to do maybe we
can reevaluate that so we don't so I
feel like pipelines is you know that
question comes up a lot so we don't
currently support pipelines because we
sort of have
under the hood that's it we're not using
we're not using pipelines under the hood
but we are doing basically the same sort
of thing you know have a sequence of
steps that we we always perform so it's
like there's always scaling before you
do you know before you apply like you
know the mapping to collapse classes you
know there's like sort of steps that we
take in order that they're always in
there that are basically a pipeline but
we didn't use a pipeline originally and
I can't remember what at this point but
it just kind of stuck around like that
well so you you could do some
pre-processing on yeah I think usually
what we're doing here is where were for
us we're usually taking data that people
have generated you know they have some
script they wrote for generating these
features and then we're just you know
performing machine learning stuff on it
so it's it's usually like the learning
and the featured generation are sort of
like very separate tasks with skul
usually but now that we added support
for custom learners I think you could
probably pretty easily use a pipe pipe
line with it I think about that but I
haven't tried that yet so you can let me
know if that breaks anything
so the reason i would suggest using
skull over scikit-learn I mean
scikit-learn is great obviously we're
building on top of scikit-learn but it's
it's just for me it's a lot simpler to
just put the other this little file and
you know hit go and have it run all the
experiments for me I mean we've taken a
lot of care to try and make sure that we
don't make common mistakes about you
know like when you're doing scaling
making sure everything is correct and we
do a lot of stuff under the hood so you
know we try it autumn when it reads
everything in and automatically reason
as a sparse matrix but then if you try
and use it with a scalar that doesn't
support sparse matrices or with a
classifier that doesn't support sparse
matrices it automatically converts it
too dense for you rather than just
crashing you know there's like a lot of
there's a lot of stuff that we do to try
and make it so it's really hard to screw
up so that's try to hold your hand a lot
print a lot of warning messages when we
do stuff like that but you know you'll
be fine and when does this actually end
1025 okay so I got five more minutes if
people have more questions oh so the the
people who don't know python so for
example I'm just thinking third my
primary area of work is I work on a
program called a Raider which is our
system for automatically grading essays
and so one of the components of that
were trying to add in is a a system for
trying to tell if essays are coherent so
it's called discourse coherence so like
is there a flow to their train of
thought as they're writing their essay
so the one of the primary people who
works on that she doesn't really do any
program you know much programming at all
but she's sort of got a bunch of data
that's annotated for coherence and then
that and then she had some engineers
like myself you know right little
scripts to examine different areas of it
so she had all these different features
that people had generated and then she
just put it together and ICS
file and pass it to skull and then was
off and running in ouch and she has a
coherence model that kind of works any
other questions yeah the slides are
already up on SlideShare I probably
should have put that well I guess how
would I put a reference to the thing
that I didn't up looking like I feel
like there's some circularity there if
there aren't any other questions I do
have bonus slides that I was saving
bonus ice so this this is actually the
the Python API in case people care what
that looks like so we've got two main
classes we've imported right here
learner and reader and you used to have
to specify which type of reader you're
using for all the different files
there's like n DJ reader mega ohm reader
CSV reader that kind of thing but then
we added this method to the reader
parent class for path so you can say I
just want the reader that works for this
file and this file ends in mega em so
just a simple look up and says okay
that's an extension that maps to this
class which is mega ohm reader and then
use called that read on that to read
everything into a training examples
which is a an object that we have called
the feature set which is basically what
we work with are these feature set
classes so if you want to train a linear
SVM you just is that making weird noises
beyond sorry that's very distracting so
learner that learner SVC is the name of
the psych and learn class so you just
pass in the name of that and that'll get
you a learner that's set up with the
default parameters and everything oh I
should mention one of the things we do
for reproducibility because a lot a lot
of you know the work we do we want to
make sure that we always get the same
results when we run the same model over
and over again so we fix the random seed
for like everything across the board has
the random seed fixed so if you run this
a you know a 10 years from now it should
still give you the exact same output
which is very important for our work in
particular
you can override that I guess if you
wanted so you just called that train
with your example set and that will
train your model now they of your
trained model you can load some test
examples and can call learner dot
evaluate on it and so learner dot
evaluate returns a tuple of a ton of
stuff which is kind of like as we're
going along we needed more and more
things that it needed to return and so
they kept adding on so we've got the
confusion matrix that shows them the
output file the overall accuracy the
precision recall and F score for each
class the tune bottle parameters and the
objective function score on the test set
and Jerry predictions is really easy
it'll give you a predictions as a I
think it's just an umpire array and then
if you want to do 10-fold
cross-validation use call cross validate
and this fold result list here is
basically a perfil version of the
results from evaluate and then in
addition that we turn the purple
training set objective scores where the
training set is the training set within
the cross-validation um and what's this
wait that didn't come up yet okay and
then the other thing is you know you
might want to write some files that's
that's actually a really nice feature is
you know for writing out of feature
files that are different formats so this
this sort of shows you how you can
create a feature set by just basically
getting a list of labels a list of ID's
a list of features where features are
just dictionaries that map from feature
names to values and you can create a
little feature set and then you can just
get the corresponding writer that can
write that type of file using the four
path thing or you can just directly say
like ND j writer dot whatever that that
should not have adopt there so it's just
just say n DJ writer and then it's the
initializer so it shouldn't have a
period there I apologize for the typo
then you just write it up and you have a
nice new line delimited JSON file so
that's the basics of what's going on
under the hood a little bit
and now my time is actually up so thank
you